hey everyone is sarah with registered
nurse or en comm and in this video I'm
going to be covering isotonic hypotonic
and hypertonic solutions and what I want
you to get out of this lecture is the
following I want you to know what's
happening to this cell when these
conditions are presenting what are the
different types of fluids that may be
ordered to help a patient who's in these
type of conditions and I want to hit on
key concepts that you need to know for
lecture exams and for the NCLEX now
after this lecture be sure to go to my
website register nurse RN calm and take
the free quiz that goes along with this
lecture it's going to test you on the
solutions it'll give you scenarios and
you'll have to pick which options are
the correct and you may see some of
these questions on a lecture exam now
the links should be in the description
below or a card should be popping up and
you can access that okay first let's
familiarize ourselves with the cell and
how osmosis works because this is the
foundation for understanding isotonic
hypotonic and hypertonic solution so
let's look at a cell okay
our body is made up of millions of these
little things and in the cell you have
the inside of your cell which has made
up of the organelles you have your
electrolyte and it's referred to as the
intracellular part of the cell then
surrounding the cell is fluid and it's
also made up of electrolyte and it's
referred to as the extra cellular so
intracellular is the inside remember in
intracellular cellular and then extra is
outside very important and then you had
your solvent and in the solvent you have
solutes and your body loves to have
everything equal it wants the same
amount on the outside that's on the
inside and if one of these conditions
like we're going to talk about here in a
second happens the body will use osmosis
to correct that and osmosis is where you
have less of the concentration trying to
move to a higher concentration through a
semipermeable membrane
so that's what's happening with osmosis
and I always like to refer to sodium and
water sodium and water love each other
especially water loves sodium and I want
to think of it like this I try to always
think of little illustrations to help me
remember things and maybe you're like
that too I like to think of sodium as
the popular kid and water is the kid
that wants to be popular and they love
hanging out with the popular kid so what
happens is that sodium sometimes likes
to congregate inside the cell or maybe
it'll shift and go to the outside but
wherever it goes water wants to go so
sodium jumps off a bridge water will
jump off a bridge so try to remember
that because that will help you remember
the hypotonic and hypertonic what's
happening because what will happen is
that you will have all this sodium
congregated inside of a cell now the
sodium on the outside of the cell there
won't be as many now according to the
rule of osmosis you will have a shift in
fluid from a less concentrated which is
the outside to a higher concentration so
all that water will want to move in to
where sodium's congregating and it can
cause different conditions first let's
go over isotonic okay isotonic iso means
equal iso and then tonic the second half
the word means concentration of the
solution so there is an equal
concentration of the solution on the
inside of the cell and on the outside of
the cell the body is happy they love it
having it like this now the type of
fluids because in the healthcare setting
we will give isotonic fluids so you
probably want to write these down
because you want to remember them there
are four of them and they are on point
nine saline a dextrose five percent in
water which is known as d5w and i have
an asterisk by that i'm going to explain
that here in a second 5% dextrose in
point two to five percent saline and in
lactated ringers also known as LR now
why do I have an asterisk by d5w now d5w
whenever you administer it before you
administer it it's considered an
isotonic solution
by after administration the body quickly
metabolizes this dextrose and after the
dextrose is gone you just have the water
left over so it turns into a hypotonic
solution so you may be reading some
literature and it will talk about it's
either a hypotonic or isotonic they use
them interchangeably for things and
that's the reason why is because your
body is absorbing that dextrose and then
after it absorbs it you're just left
over with the other fluid and that's a
hypotonic fluid so keep that in mind now
why would a patient be ordered an
isotonic fluid they are ordered to
increase the extracellular fluid volume
because what's happened is that the
patient has lost this extracellular
fluid either through blood loss
dehydration with vomiting diarrhea or
surgery again probably with the fluid
loss I mean the blood loss so we give
isotonic solutions to increase this they
won't cause a shift it won't mess up
this cell caused it to shrink or blow up
or anything like that
so we just want to replace the
extracellular fluid and that's how
isotonic solutions allow us to do that
now let's go / - Onix Aleutians hypo
means under or beneath so it's low and
tonic again is just the concentration of
the solution so the concentration of the
solution is lower than it should be
and I've tried represented in this
picture of this cell right here you have
this cell and notice extracellular Lee
you have not a wad of water molecules or
your solute which is sodium but on the
inside of the cell you have all this
water in all these solutes now according
to osmosis remember this part the
extracellular where it's less
concentrated is going to want to move
where it's more concentrated which is on
the inside of the cell so what's going
to happen is you're going to have the
shift of all this fluid that's
extracellular into the cell
intracellularly
and what will happen is that your cell
will swell up and
can license mean it can rupture and
break apart so that is what's happening
whenever you have that side-effects
again our cell lysis and another thing
you have to watch out for whenever you
have a patient in this state is that you
can deplete the circulatory systems
fluid you can make them hypovolemic
because what's happening is all this
fluid that's in the blood is leaving and
entering into the cells so they're not
going to have any more fluid left so you
really have to watch that now in the
hospital setting we like to get patients
sometimes hypotonic fluids because they
have dehydrated cells so we will give
them this fluid in certain circumstances
now there's three hypotonic solutions
that you need to remember and remember
with this because I know it gets
confusing when you're trying to remember
what isotonic what's hypotonic and
what's hypertonic and what helps me
remember this is the number of fluids
for each hypo it's low it's the less of
all three and there's only three
hypotonic solutions that you really need
to remember so and they are 0.45 percent
of saline which is half-normal saline
0.22%
of saline which is 1/4 saline and then
0.33 percent which is one-third saline
and those are generally the most popular
and again d5w what we said about with
isotonic it is sometimes used as a
hypotonic solution because the dextrose
is metabolized now why are they use and
they are used again whenever the cell
becomes dehydrated because we actually
want to move all that fluid into the
cell because it sells all shrinked up
and what what causes the cell to do that
diabetic ketoacidosis DKA will cause it
and hyperosmolar hyperglycemic will also
cause that as well so generally if you
have a patient who is in these
conditions they will be ordered one of
these solutions to help hydrate that
cell back now there are instances where
you do not want to give a hypotonic
solution and this is a popular test
question they'll give you a scenario and
they may say a patient comes in with
increased intracranial pressure and they
are ordered and point
3% normal saline would you give this and
you win because you will not give a
patient who has increased intracranial
pressure hypertonic solution because it
will shift the fluid into the brain
tissue and cause brain swelling which is
not good and patients who have burns any
type of burns and trauma because these
patients are already hypovolemic and
remember this to please your circulatory
system you don't want to do that anymore
now let's go over hypertonic okay
hypertonic hyper means excessive and
tonic again is the concentration of the
solution so you had too much of a
concentrated solution going on and let's
look at this picture to see what's going
to happen now extracellular if you
notice you have a lot of water molecules
and you have a lot of a solid solute and
but on the inside of the cell you hardly
have anything at all so remember
according to osmosis that fluid will
want to shift from a lower concentration
which is the inside of the cell to a
higher concentration where everyone else
is at so whenever that happens you're
going to have your cell just shrink up
and that is what's happened
so side effect is your cell is going to
shrink now sometimes we want to cause
this to happen because the patient has
some conditions that's going on now
water M hypertonic solutions now to help
you remember this there are six of those
six of these hypertonic so remember
hyper tonic is increased so you have six
of those fluids isotonic you just had
four of them and remember how many did
you have four hypotonic three so you
have six and what they are is three
percent saline five percent saline 10%
dextrose and water 5% dextrose in point
nine percent saline 5% dextrose in point
and we'll half-normal saline and fibrous
dextrose in LR now let me try to go over
this to help you remember the fluid
types a little bit pay attention to
these percentages because hypo looks
like a hypo hypo is less notice these
numbers these are
very low percentages of saline so they
are on the low-end row in but low
spectrum so you know that they're
hypotonic now normal you have 0.9 saline
that's a normal that's isotonic and then
the 5% and then the half with the point
to 2% saline that equals isotonic LR is
an isotonic then look over here at your
hypertonic you have these higher
percentages three percent saline five
percent saline very very salty so it's
very concentrated so just try to
whenever you're trying to analyze and
ask yourself is this a hypertonic
hypotonic isotonic fluid make sure
you're paying attention to those
percentages now these fluids are
typically given in the intensive care
unit or I'm unit that can really monitor
a patient very closely and it's given
via a central line usually because these
hypertonic solutions are very very hard
on the veins will cause full itis and
things like that and the reason you have
to normally give these in the ICU is
because a patient's condition can change
very fast if they're not monitored
closely because these fluids cause very
quickly fluid overload which can lead to
pulmonary edema and if you see here
because what's happening remember is
that all the fluid is shifting into your
vascular system because you're just
shrinking that cell up so all this is
just running through your system and if
you put too much and dehydrate those
cells too much you're going to have too
much um volume and it's going to back up
the heart's not going to be able to
handle it it's going to back up into the
lungs you're going to put them in fluid
overload so that is why they have to be
watched very carefully now why would you
give a hypertonic solution now a lot of
times you will have patients who cells
they're very swollen and we need to pull
all that stuff out of those cells into
the body so the patient can excrete them
out and get rid of it and patients with
cerebral edema we like to give that
because they because it helps decrease
the swelling by removing the fluid off
of the brain so if they have that and
you may get like 3% saline so that is
the
prints between isotonic hypotonic and
hypotonic solutions now go to my website
register nurse Orion comm and take the
quiz to see how well you know this
material and be sure to check my other
videos on fluid and electrolytes and
thank you so much for watching and
please consider subscribing to this
YouTube channel